[Musique]
ce que j'ai à dire vous est égal vous ne
voulez que confirmer ce que vous croyez
savoir ma tâche était simple jeu devait
empêcher la destruction du pays que
j'aime je ne vois pas en quoi cela
diffère de vous je suis sur la piste
d'un grand ennemi de notre peuple
adolf eichmann l'architecte de la
solution finale
on a perdu ses pistes en 46 nos
renseignements ont découvert qu'il était
à buenos aires
ce thème a convaincu des ravins de
remplir les trains eux mêmes sans
utiliser la force si c'est bien lui
il nous faut une équipe d'élite je suis
contre ce genre d'exécution
j'aimerais lui mettre une balle entre
les deux yeux mais c'est pas ce qu'on va
faire c'est une simple extradition
ashman sera jugée ici en israël
pensez aux symboles
on pourrait publiquement enfin confronté
l'homme qui a organisé notre génocide
[Musique]
le recueil de notre mémoire dépasse les
frontières de l'histoire des chapitres
s'ils écrivent encore et c'est à votre
tour d'être la plume entre nos mains
[Musique]
si vous réussissez pour la première fois
de notre histoire notre bourreau sera
sur le banc des accusés ça pourrait
dissuader quiconque voudrait marcher
dans ses pas
[Musique]
si vous échouez
il échappera à la justice peut-être pour
toujours
[Musique]
pitié
m'échouer pas
[Musique]